hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well if there's one
central concept or rule that is
associated with John Stuart Mill's essay
on Liberty it is what has come to be
called the harm principle and in fact
this is often taken as a summary of
everything that's important about the
work in general which is unfortunate
because it is worth actually looking at
all of the arguments and the examples
that he uses because it flushes out this
principal the principal is a skeleton
you might say and the flesh and organs
and inhabiting life comes from the
arguments and examples provided in the
rest of the work how do we know that it
is so absolutely central well he tells
us in the introduction the object of
this essay is to assert one very simple
principle so you might say well that's
great why not a pamphlet instead of just
a long ish you know book well because
this principle itself is going to be
simple to express but complex in its
application and in its explanations so
what is this about he says that this one
single principle governs
absolutely the dealings of society with
the individual in the way of compulsion
and control whether the means used be
physical force in the form of legal
penalties or the moral coercion of
public opinion so he's looking at the
legal realm the governmental the
political realm and he's also looking at
the broader social and cultural realm as
well which could extend very you know I
think quite reasonably into the economic
realm and other things as well the
aesthetic realm and so he's asserting
that this applies both to what the
government does and to what other
associations other things do that affect
individuals so what is the principle
word from word it runs like this the
only purpose for which power may be
rightly exercised on any member of a
civilized community against his will is
to prevent harm to others a lot of
people miss read this and they think
that you know it means that the only
purpose that any power that any person
whatsoever uses against another person
is to prevent harm to others there's a
couple provisions in there that we
actually need to look at mill uses this
term member of a civilized community if
you read other works by John Stuart Mill
particularly his discussion of
representative government but also you
know his discussions in utilitarianism
you realize that he does not mean this
to apply to every single culture he has
a you know kind of euro centric view
that thinks that certain cultures are
going to be more developed than others
and perhaps this harm principle may not
apply with within some of the less
developed ones
it also doesn't apply equally to adults
as it does to equally to children as it
to adults in part because children are
not yet completely rational even most
adults are not completely rational in
mute in Mills view either and then that
against his will that's quite important
as well if somebody enters into an
agreement say a legal contract where
they say I can be fined if I don't
deliver these goods that is you know in
accordance with his will he may not like
it at the time that he has to pay up
that there's some legal damages when he
engages in shifty or you know corrupt
behavior but that wasn't actually
against his will so there's a lot of
things being covered here so agreements
would you know limit this to some degree
but it's still a very wide application
and Mills argument for this running
throughout the work is not based on
something like rights to expression or
property or anything like that he says
this can actually be argued for on the
basis of utility or usefulness so
there's there's a basis for it that it's
not simply being asserted as such so
let's actually look at what he says here
in this this paragraph a little bit more
he says that the only purpose for which
power can rightly be exercised
preventing harm to others his own good
either physical or moral is not a
sufficient warrant why would he bring
that up well because in our own time but
even more so in Mills time and even more
so in times before is this notion well
I'm gonna exercise coercive power on you
so as to conduce to your own good to
keep you from doing something stupid to
yourself or damaging yourself in the
process or damaging your prospects or
ruining your reputation that was viewed
as as legitimate by
many people even to the point of being
able to say persecute those who hold the
wrong opinions because it's damaging to
them to believe the wrong things so this
is really a rejection of two things that
aren't brought up as such in the essay
but which we can certainly highlight one
of them is what we would call
perfectionism this notion which mill
does share that human beings can be more
or less developed that you know we have
a you know sort of scale or continuum
and we can move along that from our you
know less realized state to a more
realized state now Mill doesn't agree
that there's like one single way to
attain human perfection or if you don't
like the word perfection use the word
development use the word fulfillment but
he thinks that you can't use force to
get people to go there or what we call
paternalism paternalism is when we say
well you're not competent to make
judgments for yourself so I'm going to
step in as sort of like a good father
and make the judgments and
determinations and decisions for you and
if you don't like it I'll give you a
spanking or I'll take something away
from you I'll ground you will punish you
I'll give you extra work to do I'll
deprive you of opportunities until you
fall in line so you know prime example
of paternalism of this sort is when we
restrict people's food choices in the
open market saying you know sodas aren't
good for you which is quite true and you
can't be trusted to make your own
decisions about it because look at you
you fat slobs you keep drinking you know
giant fountain drinks you you clearly
have no self control we're gonna come
down on you and say you shall not do
that well that's paternalism Mill thinks
that that is wrong when
it's being exercised for the good of
that person which might not actually be
there good so you can't exercise power
on an individual just to try to move
them towards their good or to prevent
them from harming themselves so long as
that harm is not affecting others
another prime example of this in our own
time that this argument often gets made
about are what we call victimless crimes
for example taking certain kinds of
drugs obviously you know many drugs have
some pretty severe effects on the person
over time and you know if we're getting
to the point where say like using crack
cocaine or heroin or crystal meth tends
to lead to a process of engaging in
crime in order to be able to buy more of
it okay mill would say that's fine you
can you can restrict that but if the
person is actually able to like sit in
their own apartment and enjoy their
drugs and you know not affect their
relationships and their work and their
neighborhood mill would say you have no
business using legal penalties or even
moral coercion of public opinion against
those people so he goes on and he says a
person cannot be rightly compelled to do
or forbear because it will be better for
him to do so because it will make him
happier because in the opinions of
others to do so would be wise or even
right now notice what he says next this
doesn't mean that we have to be totally
hands-off he says that we can try to
persuade them we can engage in our own
freedom of expression and every time
that we see the person say like man I
wish you wouldn't do X because it's
hurting you that's perfectly fine to do
he says there are good reasons for
remonstrated with him remonstrated as oh
can't you see how this is harming you
holding you back
reasoning with him persuading him in
treating him but there are no good
reasons for compelling him
or visiting him with any evil in case he
do otherwise and then mill says to
justify that the conduct from which it
is desired to deter him must be
calculated to produce evil to someone
else the only part of the conduct of
anyone for which he is amenable to
society is that which concerns others so
if my you know heavy drug use or you
know drinking or tobacco use or whatever
it's going to be is and indeed affecting
others in negative ways prime example of
this with tobacco you so secondhand
smoke smokers would say I have the right
to smoke it's my body I can do what I
want and then you know we've discovered
scientifically that it's actually quite
bad for other people to be in there
while other people are puffing away and
filling their with with smoke and it has
deleterious effects on those people who
didn't choose that then you can say okay
no you can't do that and then we can
have laws like indeed we've passed
saying you can't smoke in public
buildings or you can't smoke in
restaurants or you can't smoke in bars
and we could do similar things about
other drugs if we know for example that
becoming addicted to opiate medications
is not only going to harm the person
which it does but also have a negative
effect on all sorts of other things that
impinge upon other persons then we can
we can restrict it and Mill says that in
that case the harm principle doesn't
apply says in the part which merely
concerns himself his independence is of
right absolute but when it comes to
other people
society has a stake in it so we can in
fact prevent harm to others for example
other people coercing other people he's
got some very interesting examples
discussed within the work you know one
one prime example that he discusses
quite late in in the work in Chapter
four is
the practice of polygamy among the
Latter day Saints of his time he says I
you know it's interesting that we don't
seem to have a problem when people in
other cultures are doing this but when
they're english-speaking we say it's
absolutely wrong and Mill ends up
staking a position where he says you
know those women can you know it's a
matter of religion which is a voluntary
thing if they want to they can leave
I think if Mill were to actually look at
it closer up and talk with a number of
them
he might say oh actually they are being
coerced they're out in the middle of
nowhere they're dependent so if we're
for coercing others then the state or
public opinion can indeed bring coercive
force against us if I'm beating my kids
and you know we've decided as a society
that beating is is wrong which thing
thank goodness we certainly have then
the state can come in and punish me I
you know I can't justify it by saying
it's it's my family my rights begin at
the door your rights and they're well
because somebody else is being affected
somebody else should not be harmed so
the harm principle does have quite a
scope what does it actually apply to in
Mills view in Chapter two he is going to
discuss freedom of thought and what we
nowadays call freedom of expression
freedom of opinion in his view and
freedom to publish those opinions he'll
also talk about you know character and
and what we nowadays call lifestyle the
way in which we live and then in later
chapters he's going to discuss
associations with other people and even
trade trade provides an interesting set
of examples he says that you know the
state for example can tell you you can't
trade in poisons but in general we
should we should stick with free trade
going back to the the Association and
lifestyle things here there's a nice
pass
from Chapter four in which he explains
this a bit that I think could be quite
helpful for understanding it he says
that here we go
when we look at how we regard other
people whether we think that they're
decent people or disgusting people or
somewhere in between
how they've developed in terms of human
nature whether they're nearer to the
ideal perfection of it or grossly
deficient in these qualities we're going
to have sentiments right we'll have
admiration or the opposite of it which
we might call disgust and he says that
though doing no wrong to anyone a person
may act so as to compel us to judge him
and to feel to him as a fool or as a
being of an inferior order since this
judgment and feeling are a fact which he
would prefer to avoid it is doing him a
service to warn him of it beforehand as
of any other disagreeable consequence to
which he exposes themselves so you know
we see somebody behaving badly and we
say hey you know not gonna bring any
force to bear on you but quit acting
like a jackass because people don't like
that don't be a jerk that's not
violating the harm principle as a matter
of fact it's perfectly fine to do that
he says it would be well indeed if this
go to office were more freely rendered
than the common notions of politeness
and present permit and if one person
could honestly point out to another that
he thinks him in fault without being
considered unmannerly or presuming and
he says we have a right also in various
ways to act upon our unfavorable opinion
of anyone not to the oppression of his
individuality but in the exercise of
ours very important point there can't
oppress their individuality so he says
we're not bound for example to seek his
society we have a right to avoid it
though not to parade the avoidance we
have a right to choose the society most
acceptable to us we have a right and it
may be our duty to caution others
against him we may give others a
preference over him and optional good
offices except those which attended ISM
improvement so he says in these various
modes a person may suffer very severe
penalties at the hand of others for
faults which can directly concern only
himself but he suffers these penalties
only so far as their the natural and as
it were the spontaneous consequence of
the faults themselves not because they
were purposively inflicted on him for
the sake of punishment so you know the
harm principle allows us to say I'm not
going to go to your party as a matter of
fact I don't even want to talk to you
I'm not going to friend you on social
media I may in fact block you so long as
we're not producing some sort of
coercive that harms the person it would
be different if I say well if you want
to be hired for this government position
which is open to everybody you have to
friend me on social media that would be
wrong according to the harm principle so
this gives you some idea of the scope of
it to reiterate you know the only
purpose for which power of this this
sort coercion penalties may be rightly
exercised against a person's will is to
prevent harm to others that's the harm
principle one of the key ideas of
Liberty
you